i bom dia eu é que foi de sua autoria e
eu acredito que o mundo pode ser mudado
através de uma coisa fantástica que é os
negócios e nos negócios
pode haver uma coisa fantástica também é
que é o poder das mulheres
nós todos podemos mudar o mundo podemos
contribuir para esta causa com uma coisa
muito simples que é levar o mundo
através do negócio como interessante
através do poder da mulher
já vamos falar de uma pessoa que foi
muito importante pra mim e quem deve
fugir mesmo que a minha mãe é minha mãe
sempre foi uma pessoa que me inspirou e
como deu aquilo que hoje considero ser
os traços maiores da minha personalidade
vamos contar uma história que eu acho
que é importante que é é mais ou menos a
década de 50
a imagem era casada com o meu pai e
aconteceu uma coisa que se calhar para
hoje pra vocês podem ser chocantes mas
aconteceu
quem vai ficar com o meu pai e meu pai
ficou o in vivo com a minha mãe porque
porque ela estava a chegar ao peão com
uma blusa com as mangas um pouco mais
curtas do que eu achava que uma mulher
decente de usar ficou furioso mandou
minha mãe para casa
esta história não acabou muito bem com
uma pessoa do meu pai porque minha mãe
eu viajei pra casa foi para a
universidade local o curso dela e passou
a ser a pessoa que mais dinheiro ganhou
em casa durante toda a vida
portanto ela passou a ter direitos e
passou a fazer isso ela passou a ter a
decisão para onde é que o dinheiro da
casa
se eu coisas que a minha mãe me ensinou
que dizer que eles foram hoje que os
estudos são extremamente importantes e
nunca pena de um homem para a sua vida
é por causa da minha mãe e eu pude
estudar por necessidade e foi com curso
gestão é e também aconteceu uma história
curiosa que é um dia foi entre numa
cadeira para fazer um trabalho sobre um
líder contemporâneo que de alguma forma
de versão do amor e achou que ia ser
fácil e sobem vamos encontrar uma mulher
minha surpresa foi muito grande que não
é contra ninguém
era um vazio de mulheres no mundo dos
negócios que estivessem com esta atitude
eu não desistir e paz e encontrar uma
pessoa que fez muita diferença também na
minha vida
foi essa senhora não sei se vocês
conhecem esta é então blog anita roddick
foi a fundadora de uma empresa inglesa
muito conhecida que chamou ao shopping é
que na altura quando eu conheci já era
uma empresa gigante gera uma empresa que
tinha levado o mundo através de negócio
baseado naquilo caneta acreditava e
baseado em fazer melhor por ao mundo
ainda que a empresa fosse uma empresa
lucrativa usaram se passaram e nenhum
empreendedora com vários objetos e
adoçantes de 3 anos atrás eu e mais duas
mulheres juntas anos e criamos aquilo
que nos unir
- era que nós éramos apaixonados quer um
chá passo e queríamos criar uma marca
luxo café em portugal ficava se esquecem
que são ajustes finos mas quando nós
começamos um projeto novo
temos que ter em atenção alguma coisa
quer responder esta está a responder à
questão
o problema é que nós vamos resolver e
nós vamos resolver um problema que eu
acho que não vai haver forma de resolver
no futuro próximo que é as mulheres
interessa para o suficiente no seu
roteiro
eu sou feliz problema é que tem muita
gente que não é só
e como achava que ia ser um problema
demasiado eles vão resolver em cima
resolver outro problema que foi mudar o
mundo através de negócio e fazer um
forma fazê lo através de pequenos gestos
focam não vou dar mais poder às mulheres
porque a mulher é um agente de mudança
muito positivo no mundo o que nós
acreditamos que nós acreditamos pequenos
gestos fazem grandes acontecimentos
nós decidimos mudar as vidas da forma
que nós tivemos melhor do que é
fizemos sapatos e unhas sapatos que
visam ajudar não só mulheres como também
crianças e pretende países desenvolvidos
nós sabemos que uma mulher é uma agenda
é um agente mudança positiva e cria
ciclo de mudança muito positivos
é o que nós fazemos é que o lucro que
vai e vem que vem desses produtos que
nós vendemos não me alimentar suas
edições especiais vai diretamente para
essas mulheres elas durante um ano vão
aprender mas vamos lá e vão aprender
coisas como por exemplo cuidar da sua
saúde vão aprender uma profissão nova
vão ao final deste ano elas vão
conseguir ter um negócio próprio e vão
conseguir ser independente e o que
acontece com estas mulheres estas
mulheres
está provado que 90 por cento de seu
rendimento é reinvestido na comunidade e
não só
r esse estilo enviar seus filhos à
escola consegue esperar ciclo
positividade para as meninas nós
investimos nós tínhamos que fazer nós
por elas durante um era também a cada
uma
o material escolar que é necessário mas
a outra coisa também muito importante
que vocês podem ver o ir na imagem que
elas vão ver são os uniformes escolares
sem uniformes escolares não podem ir à
escola e quando há dinheiro para pagar a
reforma escolar normalmente elas são
preteridos em relação a elas
mas por que as meninas teoricamente
devem ficar em casa a fazer trabalhos
domésticos e nós acreditamos que com
este pequeno gesto vamos mesmo levar o
mundo e que essas meninas quando cheira
vão ser mais saudáveis vão ser em vão
ganhar mais dinheiro e acontece também
uma coisa fantástica elas enviam os seus
filhos também para a escola
por isso nós acreditamos que uma mulher
mais forte
criam-se e dados mais fortes e mais
fluência
mas nós não atuando só na área do do
país de ser humano nós também
preocupante com a nossa comida aqui em
portugal e o que acontece é que nós
fazemos calçado luxo é com vocês que
dançava e precisamos sempre detalhes
nesses calçado nomeadamente sá
o vate packaging outros índios e outras
coisas nós nos sintamos e ainda que nós
vamos sempre buscar nós temos cá
empresas são dirigidas por mulheres
ouvidas por mulheres
essas empresas nós acreditamos
contribuir de alguma forma para que elas
cresçam e pra que é hoje a nossa forma
também possam ser mais mas silas porque
por uma mulher no momento quando ser um
negócio ela fala de uma coisa que ela é
apaixonada nós somos um exemplo disse
nós sapato porque é isso as mulheres
procuram ter negócio com elas são
apaixonadas e o que acontece quando uma
pessoa é apaixonada por um negócio ou
por uma coisa que faz ela vai fazer lá
muito melhor do que uma pessoa que não é
tão apaixonada e por isso nós
conseguimos ter este beck é juliet de
facto quando tem um negócio fazer sempre
melhor do que um homem
regra geral
por isso
é falado e roubado elas são mais
apaixonadas por isso para as pessoas que
estão aqui pra quem tem filhas para quem
tem crianças e jovens meninas
estávamos deixaram opel que é em si nem
as vossas filhas aqui o que minha mãe me
ensinou que é muito importante
titular ou acreditar nelas próprias
nunca depender em nomes e terá expressa
próprio porque é muito importante
especialmente numa época como esta e
acima tudo o mundo precisa de mais
mulheres empreendedoras e as mulheres
empreendedoras precisam de todos nós
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]